[Music]
all right so with uh
with the world ending ending yes
yeah earlier we talked about like
another episode about a [ __ ]
condo underground like the researchers
preparing for some crazy [ __ ] the world
is going through some crazy [ __ ]
let's talk about happiness right now
thank god happy
new year how it's gone from this world
ah
yeah how happy it is penis
happiness
now you got it penis i like my husband
yeah like mine yes
happiness
i happiness okay happy happy happiness
yes
i have penis my i'm the youngest one in
the room
what
but yeah happiness is all i hear is
penis now
god damn it penises are very elusive
and very fleeting would you say would
you agree
that they move around and stuff like you
can't get me happiness happiness
oh happiness no penis penis what are we
talking about
through the [ __ ] wrench we'll never
get through this article
penises are hard to crap yes very
especially if you do the thing where you
do the bounce spouse and they're like
trying to grab it
happiness is fleeting hmm happiness is
never permanent is what i'm saying
it's not permanent well sadness isn't
either i know it's like
some people love that [ __ ] somebody love
it yeah [ __ ] yeah i think more people
like it than happiness
yeah i think people like a misery is
like a good company
true you know but yeah so
i don't know i feel like there's a lot
of like unhappiness in the world and i
think a lot of people are trying to
seek answers and find happiness and
stuff and i came across this article
[ __ ] you don't find happiness you
manufacture it
you manufacture it that's that's true
how do you say some profound [ __ ] while
[ __ ]
scratching your [ __ ] back while
having one eye twitching and [ __ ]
do you ever do that when you scratch and
then you're like oh
good no [ __ ] it never is
why it's just you say some profound [ __ ]
you know like it's very valid it was
very smart very wise but
you just look crazy from my angle
sometimes it looks nothing like he's
saying some like crazy [ __ ] he's like
being all masculine and like talking
about some [ __ ] and like like punishing
people and then
but underneath the table he's like
sitting like like this and like he's
like i was like stretched out like this
i'm paint me like one of your french
girls he was saying that earlier but his
feet why are you talking
about kill yourself
[Laughter]
i [ __ ] kill your ass [ __ ]
[ __ ] kill you
[ __ ] but yeah you're saying uh
happiness is manufactured yeah what does
that mean to you
you have to uh so feelings and things
are
uh um are are generated from
our minds and our hearts like inside
right even though we can react
to whatever's going on out there but i
think people want to search for it like
they need to go
and get inspired they need to feel
something from the outside in but it's
generated from the in
so like for example um your brain is
experiencing
all these senses that's happening in
your body
like if you taste if you smell if you
hear all of this
is just like senses that you're
experiencing
and you're you can't choose to
experience it or or
or you can choose to make sense of what
you're experiencing right
i don't know if i'm making any sense
yeah it's like a uh it's very fleeting
and elusive yeah like we can all see the
same thing but how we experience it
internally is completely different
yeah but a lot of people think that
happiness is something that you
get or obtain or like like with
materialism right like you go oh when i
get that car would be so happy
yeah when i get that or like even goal
chasing right you're like oh when i
finally get that job i want i'm gonna be
so
happy well you never know that's true
yeah you went for a split second and
then
it's fleeting but it but it goes away
eventually getting the new
shirt and the car goes away yeah waiting
for it is the most fun part
right oh [ __ ] it's coming then you get
it you're like cool
that's true day or two and you're gone
that's it that's true yeah so
uh one of the reasons why happiness is
so fleeting and elusive
what joe was saying it's happiness
itself is adaptive
depending on where your starting point
is uh
you know getting say for example uh you
know
we want to be we want to make a movie
and maybe the idea of making a movie
right now
uh will bring us happiness you know and
once we get there we're like yeah we're
happy
but then the adaptive part about
happiness and sadness
is that once we have made a movie and
then we're at that plateau
say if there's a plateau there then we
view ourselves as
we have only made one movie yeah what do
you want to do next and then
when now all of a sudden we're back to
sadness and we need to find another way
to get our happiness back
so it's always adaptive depending on
where your position is and kind of like
where you're looking forward to it's
always gonna be
uh proportionate to that right yeah i
think it's also
where like you said where it's it's
things that you look forward to or you
put like
a happiness on like a goal marker or
whatever but instead of just being
happy with where you are now and like
the progress of now even though
you still want those things you know i
feel like that's where people are i'm
like
and people just like use other people or
i don't know who said they like to be
sad
where i'm like i feel like yeah they
they purposely do things that make them
even more sad maybe
subconsciously yeah like i don't go and
like put on sad music
because i know it gives me different
types of feelings i put on happy music
because
i want to be happy or i also look at
life in a different way than
most people i remember watching like
non-stop negative documentaries
and like super violent videos and i mean
i mean uh shows and like after a whole
week of binge watching
crazy [ __ ] i could feel myself feeling
just
sad and the world's like in a bad place
and i feel like everything's [ __ ] up
and i was like oh [ __ ]
i didn't monitor the [ __ ] that was going
in my brain
and what i was registering and so like
for example
if you arguing every [ __ ] day on
twitter right you're gonna think
that people are so confrontational and
so [ __ ] up and you're gonna be really
depressed
but like if you don't control any of
those actions
then uh you kind of self-induce
uh your your negative experiences
without knowing it
or just going on social media in general
you don't even have to argue
just but it's like just reading [ __ ]
comments yeah all you see is negativity
in the world going on
all you see is people living a better
life and for you you're like oh damn i
don't have any of these things all i see
is negativity and then you're just like
damn i love sucks this world sucks
that's true
yeah another reason uh for for people
trying to find happiness and unable to
attain it
is that a lot of us we view happiness as
one thing but happiness is not
necessarily just one thing it's many
factors in our lives that bring us
happiness
for example uh this article brings up
the example of
uh you know one some people might choose
career
and marriage as their top priorities and
they'll keep chasing that and work at
that
but in order to have a solid career and
to really develop a strong
marriage you have to let go say when
you're younger you're partying hanging
out with your homies and stuff like that
part of that has to die in order to find
the happiness that you're
reaching for with the marriage in your
career or
maybe you say you forego the marriage
you know and have a little space there
to maybe party a little bit more and
hang out with your friends
but then if you ever feel lonely and sad
and not necessarily having a
you know a partner to confide in 100
percent then that's kind of like the
bargain you're you're going down you
know you're going towards and
so it's like you kind of have to analyze
your own life and the different
components
in terms of finding what happiness is to
you do you guys listen to
uh jaco's podcast chaka williams navy
seal
i don't listen to him either but when he
comes on joe rogan i really like it
but he talks about this concept what he
calls good which is like a very common
concept in the military that i really
really liked
so and then like in military like when
something
happens like i run out of ammo good i'll
kill him with my knife
or it's [ __ ] freezing good i want it
to be harder you know so everything
you're constantly
conditioning yourself and practicing any
challenge
any negativity you embrace it and so
you're almost
like exercising that happiness muscle so
that your happiness
cardio is insanely strong and really
really good
almost like in the 300 movie where
they're like we're gonna
we'll cover the sky with arrows and then
we'll fight in the shade you know it's
kind of like
that concept and that's that concept i i
really really like cause i think like
people think that happiness is
stimulated from the outside but it
really is
how you look at how you look at stuff
it's your perspective on the inside but
if your
happiness muscle it never gets worked
out it takes
a it takes a lot for you to be happy but
if you constantly exercise and
everything is good
your car gets scratched or things that
seemingly are supposed to only have a
negative emotion but
you're able to constantly be able to
manufacture that positive emotion then
you can
be a much happier person i also think
that our society now
has this like illusion or like this
weird
thing of like you have to be happy like
i have to find myself i have to find my
happiness i have to be happy like
there's so much pressure to constantly
be happy um and i don't think that's
very human
yeah like 24 7 you're always [ __ ]
happy we think that
that's how humans should live like i'm
always in my [ __ ]
zone like i'm i'm in my passions i'm
doing this and it's like
how like that's [ __ ] up that's weird
like it's not life
yes life isn't linear like that no
illusion or like social media right
everyone looks like they're always
having a blast on social media doing all
this crazy [ __ ]
when they're probably at home posting up
old photos i wanted to uh
just especially learning about a lot of
things now during the the whole
quarantine time and just like
how everything is done i love america
like it's i don't think i'd ever want to
move but like if i did decide to move i
think i would go to like
finland or like denmark or something
like a norwegian country because
there they always rank um number one on
the happiness
it's like the happiness index that the
the um puts on it's the
it's a very like they they interview a
lot of people
they're like who's this non-white guy
no they have other people there's a lot
of like other cultures and stuff but
then uh
one of the things is like they measured
uh income and like once you have enough
income to uh survive and like make money
more income doesn't bring more happiness
yeah
you know and that's like one thing that
we're taught here where it's
um it's about hustling doing this not
stopping where that's not really where
you find happiness and
a lot of people do but it's also that
most people
aren't doing it they think that they
have to and they think like
they're putting all the stress of like i
got gotta stop doing this i gotta stop
doing this like the hustle
yeah the hustle matati and they practice
this thing called uh hygge
it's it's spelled like hygge or
something but the whole thing is like to
indulge and like
take part of like relaxing and uh eating
those foods that are bad for you
practicing sinful um pleasures and all
these things and sinful pleasures
anything anything yeah yeah uh but it's
like being okay with
doing that stuff and like embracing it
you know instead of being like oh i ate
this now
i'm bad no you're purposely intensely
eating it or doing those things because
you know it's bad
and it's like you're being okay with it
yeah yeah so here it's like i eat this
cookie my
my my [ __ ] diets ruined i'm gonna be
a fat piece of [ __ ] and these people are
gonna love me because i'm fat
uh i gotta do this this this i could
increase the happiness of
men by sixty percent hell more blow jobs
why did you come up with sixty i just do
it out there that's 69
59 missed opportunity bro
but the last reason why happiness is so
fleeting and elusive
is that we also uh uh compare our
happiness to past
and present so we always look at
statistically a lot of people look
at the past through rose-colored glasses
we kind of remember the feelings of a
certain time
that brought us happiness and we were
always trying to measure up our present
to that past or maybe why that's why i
feel like i'm happy
because it sucked back then so
everything's awesome right now
true that's great so maybe we should
have really bad pass
on purpose to my mom for that horrible
childhood
hey some people will blame their
horrible childhood but if you can look
back and go
hey you set the bar so low that
everything is amazing
of life is amazing thanks mom unless
you're traumatized
true
you